The joe rogan experience.
I got a story that I don't want to
tell because in front of my girlfriend,
because it will upset because a,
I would make my life a bit harder
and I don't want to tell it on,
on any tonight shows or anything.
So I'll tell her here.
But I just did a Zombie
movie in Australia,
which isn't anything to do with the story,
but they're always in Australia.
And so,
I mean,
it's dry.
And my parents drive to Canberra where
we were at on the weekend to spend a day
with me.
It's fair enough.
I don't see my parents and
in six months or something,
so I'm spending time with my mom and dad.
Now back in the early nineties my father
was getting closer to retirement and
then he found a credit card bill because
my mother took care of the money fan at
that.
She'd run up $90,000 worth of bills,
which made my dad had to work an extra
sort of eight years past retirement to
pay these all often
she'd kept it all secret.
All right.
So now my parents who've
got to retirement,
they own the house and they just get a
pension of like Australian government
gives each person like
$300 a week pension,
which is like two 60 American,
right?
So my parents live off that and then,
but my father takes care of all the money.
He pays all the bills and he bounced books
cause my mom can't be trusted when it
comes to shopping.
And so I'm talking to my parents,
my mom goes,
all I want is my half of the money,
his half of the money and then we'll see.
He can have his half of the money,
it will split the bills and then I
can do what I want with my money.
But instead I'm given an allowance
because I'm not responsible enough money.
I said,
mom,
you can't take care of the money ma'am.
You can't because you'll fuck it up.
You'll go online,
you've,
you've found Internet shopping
now you'll fuck it up,
you'll get rid of,
you'll lose everything
and get more credit.
Cards will be terrible.
And she goes,
Oh,
I'm not the problem with money anymore.
Your father's the one
that spends all the money.
Now we're in a public bar,
by the way.
There's many people sitting around us.
It's a very public,
open area.
Your father's the one who spends all
the money now and then she pointed,
my dad goes,
tell him,
tell him what you spend your money on.
And I've already clicked what
this white be and I've gone,
oh no,
wait,
look,
I don't want to know.
And then what my,
there goes.
Your father gets prostitutes,
right?
And I've gone,
oh,
just shut up both of your
police and she's gone.
Yeah.
Every Wednesday your father,
before he goes to play
lawn bowls goes off.
It gets himself a prostitute.
And then my dad went,
not every Wednesday,
not
every Wednesday may seem,
sounds like at least three
out of four Wednesdays.
It takes a week.
Cough every now and again,
like it costs,
you mean Australian money
for a very cheap prostitute.
It's legal in Australia in a brothel,
maybe a hundred bucks for a pretty low
end sort of girl or Robin tag power.
So he went to a place to get it done.
He didn't?
No,
no,
no.
It's not like here where you've got to
go to a hotel and that type of stuff.
They just brothels in there.
They're very league and they've
very well sign posted and stuff.
It's not,
it's not such a big deal in Australia.
It's actually makes it a bit safer,
if anything,
because the girls have to get tested.
They have to bring their
results in all the time,
and they're paying tax.
He makes it safer.
It's like else.
As soon as the government
says it can't be a legal,
when it's something that
people really enjoy doing,
low is doesn't work substantially,
of course does.
Sure it does.
Yeah.
I don't begrudge my dad for doing this.
I just don't want to hear about it.
They're in their seventies
my mom's morbidly obese.
My Dad's still quite fit.
Of course.
He wants to get his ender way sometimes.
Okay.